bonjour madame aux études et aux
facteurs vous allez beaucoup de courrier
pour moi j'adore ça beaucoup trop oui
données voilà mademoiselle julie benoit
z jolie mademoiselle julie mademoiselle
julie mademoiselle je l'aimais six
facteurs les malades ou une roja ah non
non non non non non non non c'est pas de
refus mais aujourd'hui je n'ai pas le
temps c'est la première fois que
plusieurs rafraîchissement facteurs oui
je vous remercie mais pas aujourd'hui
bon façon à françois maintenant alors
françois bonjour facteur journal
aujourd'hui non pas du tout une 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 des tons la laddh il est
formidable je bats moqueront encore des
courriers ouais ben moi je bats mon
propre record de facteur le plus chargé
ça c'est bien vrai vecteur ça alors il
est parti il est parti sans abri renvoi
mais qu'est ce qui lui arrive j'en sais
rien julie et lucie jeanfils calme si
doux d'habitude depuis quelques temps il
est bien nerveux foetus et françois nous
recevons de plus en plus de courriers
alors ça lui donne beaucoup de travail
le pauvre il ne sait plus où donner de
la tête
olala c'est plus une vie avec joly et
françois passe encore une dizaine de
lettres chacun par jour là et puis au
moins je sais où les trouver mais alors
avec casimir là là là c'est pas possible
plus de 100 lettres presque tous et
autant de cadeaux de jouets afin de deux
colis n'en fait-il encore casimir
casimir
quasi muet et cette voix célestes qui me
charme ah c'est vous et milan qu'elle
voit quelle puissance à saint nazaire
rémy campagne le meilleur des facteurs
et casimir casimir est le moment de
compliments s'est passé ça ne prend pas
ça me prend plus loin mes coups étaient
ou à telle que je lui flanque une
correction de qui elle est enfin la
mousse qui vous a piqué est mis de
mauvaise humeur au casimir tiens je vais
te donner ton courrier il avoir un teint
mon voilà tout ça
- vous voilà à tous et mona tu en as
rhin je vais paraître trois heures pour
trier tout ça on va écouter je suis
désolé pour vous mais ravi pour moi
d'abord parce que j'adore recevoir du
courrier et puis c'est pas de ma faute
si je suis si populaire mais enfin
casimir tu souhaites tu sais très bien
que je je je parle comme ça puis mais
dans le fond je ne t'en veux pas bon
coûte casimir tu vas me rendre service
si tu as vu monsieur du snob et
mademoiselle futé mende il mois prévient
les chercheurs sont justement en grande
discussion sur la promenade du bord de
mer là bas à la abonde givet alors tient
bien
merci quand même pour le renseignement
ah oui oui merci merci c'est vrai casino
merci à
pour une fois j'ai de la chance je vais
trouver deux personnes d'un seul coup
mach est raide mais quelle est cette
personne qui vient à notre rencontre
s'installer dans les yeux
on enfin vous devriez comprendre mon
chien fulbert ans elle mettait en place
et comme vous moi aussi je le soleil
dans les yeux en plus il me semble
reconnaître la fine silhouette de julie
vous avez sur moi j'espère qu'on mettra
casimir attendait non c'est notre cher
emile campagne le pacte mais oui c'est
bien avec la consolidant les jeunes le
distinguo couleurs rien vous étiez en
train de jouer et essayer de deviner qui
vous étiez viennent la chance d'avoir le
temps de jouer pas bon mademoiselle mais
voilà votre courrier merci monsieur
emile comme c'est touchant tous les
enfants qui nous écrit
voilà matchs du ch ob toutes ces lettres
à champoz rui et ses colis à une merde
merci beaucoup aimé il à aja d'or
recevoir de courrier mais ce qui me
frappe tig énormément c'est de les
ouvrir
accepteriez-vous chaire est menée de ne
servir de secrétaire de faire ce travail
à ma place pourquoi pas vu sa fille mère
c'est une idée à tous de bien creuse
entre ziari
ah oui attendez un instant s'il vous
plaît françois est ce que tu veux aller
chercher le vainqueur s'il te plait
enlevez google d'accord secteur rudement
de téléphone non décidément
oui c'est vous cher à wisches en retard
mais que voulez vous j'ai tellement de
courrier 10 fois plus qu'avant on est
pas content chef et bien je vous donne
ma démission monsieur au revoir
françois qu'est-ce que ça une démission
c'est un cadeau que je me redonner son
émission ça veut dire à abandonner un
travail emile ne veut plus être le
facteur
vous dites ça parce que vous êtes en
colère quand je vous en prie regardez
moi bien une dernière fois en uniforme
car demain c'est dans six villes que
vous retrouverez emile campagne j'ai vu
alors demain
ma photo
ne vous inquiétez pas le facteur va pas
nous quitter faites moi confiance
j'ai imité